majority of data in the world actually
still sits in these repositories and so
that's really the vision of how do we
liberate this stuff or mobilize this
stuff so that you are free to build it
wherever you want now freedom comes into
place though right you have to make sure
that you're doing the proper things to
it right that you're securing it that
you're managing it so when stuff breaks
or go sideways or whatever else
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
talking about data mobility with gary
hagmuler the ceo of archeon
gary is the ceo of archeon the world's
first true data mobility platform
gary is a proven ceo who has created
over 7.5 billion dollars in enterprise
value through two ipos and four m a
exits over his 20 plus years in the tech
industry gary holds an mba from the
marshall school of business at the
university of southern california where
he was named chef fellow as well as a
bachelor's in business administration
from arizona state university as the
father to twin teenage boys he is
clearly experienced in project
management and negotiating skills
you know we're talking about software
engineering data pipelines and
entrepreneurship at the same time this
is the you know this is my world this is
what i wake up in the morning for so
thank you very very much for being here
okay you know your entrepreneurial
career your executive career is spends
across a variety of organizations you've
done
fascinating things but but really in
this 20 minutes i want to focus with you
on picking your brain about this data
mobility question of the world data you
know
mark andreessen said i think a decade
ago software is eating the world but
really it's all about data and this is
how we make decisions
from government to social to um the way
we build companies and so yeah gary
thank you very much for being here yeah
of course my pleasure
well data in your perspective choosing
to go on another entrepreneurial
endeavor yeah with archaean why data
mobility what is this thing that you
have with data
well no look it's a great question and i
love your you know software will eat the
world analogy earlier the truth is that
software all runs on data right and so
if you don't get the data to the
software you know the world doesn't run
so the the the back story here is my my
coming to archimonde and trying to
figure out how to mobilize data uh and
get access to stuff is really rooted in
my background right which over about 10
years or so of doing machine learning
and ai that was you know building
applications that were sold to financial
services firms and all these large
companies what i became aware of very
acutely was the fact that all of these
folks had lots of really interesting and
valuable information locked up in their
transactional databases
didn't really have a good way to get
there and it struck me it's like super
odd because i'm like you know these
transactions are the lifeblood of the
businesses that they were running and
yet they were relegated to seeing them
on like let's say a a weekly or a
monthly or some other you know batch
periodic sort of update and for me the
thunk was like look all the value or
much of the value in that data is gone a
week after the transaction is over right
because think about all the things you
can do very close to the to the point at
which somebody interacts with your
business
so that's really the genesis of why i
decided that archeon was the right move
here because frankly what the world
needs right now is the ability to tap
into data in real time without affecting
those systems and making sure that the
people who can
you know build applications or machine
learning or whatever it is that that
they're going to reap value out of that
data um have access to it in real time
and that's basically what we do and um
it's been a it's been a great journey
for the last couple of months as we uh
as we start spreading the message
phenomenal and so if we're looking now
at
this the question of why hasn't it
happened yet right because this is an
important question we have to consider
and i'm thinking obviously data is
running everything everything is about
data and and obviously i want to have
visibility transparency and integration
with all the different data points
especially you know those more obscure
ones unstructured ones etc
why are we in 2022 and it's still a
problem that's not solved yeah so i
think it breaks into two basic
categories right so the category one is
um really a function of the systems
within which that data lives um and
category number two is really a function
of the nature of of the transactional
data and all that so let's start with
the first category right so while you
and i michael are kind of
entrepreneurial and we think of the
world as like all the things that it
should be as soon as you build one of
these companies and and you know let's
say you build like an oracle or whatever
else you kind of have an incentive to
keep the data in there as much as
possible right because that enhances
your value right so thing number one is
there's a bit of a business driver or a
structural sort of driver that has
successful companies that build um
repositories want to keep the data in so
that's issue number one
issue number two is is a little bit more
prosaic right and that is the fact that
you know when you have a transactional
database you want to make sure of a
bunch of things number one you can't
afford to have that thing slow down
right so you can't hammer the thing on a
regular basis right
the second thing is you want to make
sure that it's highly secure right you
can't have people dinking around in a
production database because it's going
to affect any number of things
downstream right so there's some
structural reasons why you want to
create separation between the
transactions themselves and the
downstream things that will end up
consuming it so when you put those two
things together it really forms this
thing that has helped perpetuate the
silos that we all
talked about and write papers about and
all of that sort of thing right but but
in reality unless you have something
like which what archeon is which kind of
sits just outside the production systems
and taps into the logs
and then reassembles things into kind of
a database without necessarily the
repository
um you're not going to be able to get
out those things in a way that works
both for the structural elements of the
company's motives as well as the
security and performance characteristics
that i t groups require right so so walk
me through the process if i'm right now
leading an organization and i have a
bunch of transactional data it can be
any organization any any business and
and you are coming and you're trying to
shine light for me as to what i may have
blind spots and what i may be missing
from not being able to leverage on this
data that our kiana is able to put
together what is sort of that pitch
looks like
well so i mean at the pitch basically
looks like what my customers used to go
through right so when we would build
these applications all the business
users or the data scientists or you know
the data engineers would want to see
this stuff come out in real time right
because it would make their models more
performant and accurate and everything
else like that but what would wind up
happening is their it groups would say
like hey that's great but you're going
to impact my production system you can
have it maybe weekly in some kind of a
batch or monthly which was a really
common sort of thing
so the pitch for us now is is kind of a
two-step pitch number one we spend a lot
of time partnering with the systems that
consume our data so think all these
cloud repositories snowflake data bricks
you know the list is actually quite long
we've got a number of partnerships right
and so
we work with them because they have an
incentive to help these customers of
ours or our joint customers get access
to the data because they're the
platforms that they will interact with
um on it so they go to the data
scientists or the data engineers or
sometimes even the business users and
say hey you know we have this way that
we can go off and help you get access to
these transactional things so you can
build these really cool
you know applications or whatever around
them so then those folks get interested
in it and there's a process that goes on
within the larger organizations uh our
customer organizations
where they go to their the people who
actually own the data repositories
um and then it becomes an education step
for us where we show them how we're not
going to impact their
um you know their systems and our
security profiles actually far superior
than anything that they might be able to
do
um and really what happens at first is
there's kind of an adversarial hey don't
touch my systems
sort of stance that flips very rapidly
to like oh hey i don't like writing
scripts and batch updates and that sort
of thing anyway so this seems like it's
really going to solve a lot of those
problems without impacting my world and
they become advocates pretty quickly so
that's kind of this this motion that we
see in most of our sales cycles
and the interesting thing is
the id groups actually want to becoming
our biggest champions shortly after the
first implementation goes live because
now a lot of the people who and nobody
likes to write scripts by the way so a
lot of the people who were in the it
groups writing these query things that
would go against the database break all
the time would would turn around and say
like i don't have to do that anymore
this is great i can go off and do the
things that i used to like to do before
somebody made me go write scripts and
other stuff like that so they wind up
being our biggest champions for other
people who have these sorts of needs
incredible okay and if we're looking at
uh if we're looking today at the the the
bigger world and where we're moving with
data beyond archaeon you know how is how
is this going to impact the way that we
are able to make sense of transactions
of logs of data that is happening that
right now we don't have access to well i
look i think that's that's the really
the end goal here and so you know from
my perspective and from our company's
perspective our view is
um data it really goes back to the
concept of mobility right you should be
free to build whatever application or
machine learning
use or ai
whatever it is in whatever
you know uh platform makes the most
sense for the application you're trying
to build right and so you can see that
happening today there's certain cloud
vendors who are good at machine learning
there's others that are good at bi
there's others that are good at real
time but our view is it doesn't matter
right whatever your use case is go pick
the right choice for you right the data
should just come to you right um and it
shouldn't matter where it's from like so
today there's a lot of decent solutions
if you want to get things out of let's
say salesforce or you know servicenow or
other things um but those things are
already built to kind of give you the
feeds right they're kind of event-driven
sorts of things but the majority of data
in the world actually still sits in
these repositories and so that's really
the vision of how do we liberate this
stuff or mobilize this stuff so that you
are free to build it wherever you want
now freedom comes into place though
right you have to make sure that you're
doing the proper things to it right that
you're securing it that you're managing
it so when stuff breaks or go sideways
or whatever else right you need a
platform to basically manage that that's
what we build and my view is look if we
don't build a management layer over this
sort of thing
you're basically just going to change
the profile of the resources you have to
hire in these it groups into ones that
build the pipes into this army of people
that has to now go and debug stuff and
you know make sure stuff is running
and that feels like you should be able
to very easily
build a layer that will control that and
make it pretty seamless that's what
we're doing and when you do that you
then get to a world where you can dream
the big thoughts and you can come up
with interesting things you can you can
experiment better right i mean that's
like half the battle that we were seeing
with the the data science teams of our
customers they wanted to go off and be
creative and they would be stuck
figuring out how the heck do i get like
the data to get creative in right so
that's kind of the big vision of what we
want to do here and i think that
creativity then drives lots of business
value and lots of innovation
i love it you know i spent some quality
time as a data engineer and data
scientists in various organizations and
i remember you know that that thrill of
being able to finally have my data set
and being able to play around with it
only to two days later saying oh no i
i'm now i'm now i understand there's
this whole of the world that i don't
have access to let's go on this
two-month project to get access to it
just so that i can be creative
and it's a you like come join my sales
team that is exactly good that is
exactly the pitch right and that's
actually what the software does too we
have this thing that we call inference
where what happens is when you update a
thing in a transactional database
sometimes it goes to multiple different
tables and there's all these interesting
business rules but what's really lacking
in a lot of the um
the pipeline creation mode today is the
understanding that like hey there's this
rule and if you don't get all this other
data your analysis is never going to be
complete or it's never going to be
accurate or performant right and so
that's really one of the big pitches
that we have to the data teams which is
why go through this tortured process of
iteration and then begging people to
like give you more access to more things
when you should just be able to say i
want
this set of things up front
so transitioning more towards you know
the leadership side of the startup this
is not your first role
as an executive within a within a
company we've held so many interesting
roles from director to see chief
operating officer the chief financial
officer and working at the and president
and ceo of clara analytics and so still
in the data space and then ceo of d
graph labs for for several months and
i'm i'm really curious what what you're
taking with you
from these roles as you're now entering
a new you know sf based startup that is
in one of the hottest spaces you know in
the world today yeah what what are you
taking with you as this entrepreneur now
well so i think so the main things that
i take so number one um i think
for me like personally this
entrepreneurial journey there's there's
like a mental
you know acuity sort of stuff i you know
i'm kind of an adrenaline junkie right
and like if there aren't like 15 things
going on at the same period of time i'm
going to be bored and then my wife gets
mad at me right and so you know those
are all those are all things that that
drive me forward but in terms of like
how to do this sort of stuff
look a couple of things right i think
the most important thing you can do as
somebody who's entrepreneurial or
building a business or whatever else is
really focus in on the people around you
right these things don't get built alone
right and they get built with the team
that basically is like-minded
and is is one that drives each other and
that doesn't by the way that doesn't
mean that like everybody just is you
know thinking the same way in fact i i
actually really rather enjoy having
people around who will push not in a
rude way or anything else like that but
we'll basically push him and say is are
we really doing the right thing are we
really spending the right the focus on
the right stuff
right so so number one the thing that i
take with me from the experience in the
past is making absolutely sure that
you've got a team of great people around
you um and i'm really blessed here at
at archeon in that a number of people
who i thought the world of
um prior to coming here decided that hey
this would be an interesting place for
them to come and spend some more time so
for me personally that's something that
you know
that really drives me and makes me feel
great on that front
you know and then the second piece is
you know the the interesting thing about
being an entrepreneur in a in a tech
company is tech companies if you do it
right you know they can do everything
right you can you can build software
that does just about anything the real
challenge though is not doing everything
right just because you can do it doesn't
mean you should do it it's really
netting down to what is most important
be it customers
be it developing certain aspects of the
technology to make it strategically
valuable what have you right it's making
sure that you do
just enough to create value but not so
much that you create diffusion and if
you combine those two sorts of things
and it usually takes a mature profile of
people who
um will come and join you then you wind
up in this this wonderful world where
magic kind of happens and markets kind
of move forward and you can transform
stuff
starting a new company in december
you know you've also spent several
months
as an eir with red point ventures
any big surprises that you're like okay
now i'm going on this journey i've been
on this journey before i've sat
next to people who've been at this seat
that you're in right now for many years
what surprised you now so
so the company first off i joined it it
was started in december but that's okay
um you know the the the main gist of
surprise for me is well a couple things
right so
i think that the earliest form of
surprise on this journey here was how
receptive companies like i mentioned
earlier like data breaks who invested in
our last round and others the big
surprise was how receptive those
companies would be to partnering with us
now having spent a bunch of years
in startup sorts of companies the amount
of partner interest in this firm at our
stage is more than i've ever seen before
right usually what happens in these
partner discussions is you spend a year
or two
talking about stuff right without any
real demonstrable movement forward right
whereas in here we've got partners
pushing up so i've got emails and you
know slack texts from people saying like
hey what is our connection going to get
done when is this thing going to get
done what are you going to jump on these
deals right which is which is awesome it
tells us that there's a lot of
interesting things out there it does fit
into the same uh prioritization bucket
then too though right you have to go and
pick the partners who you know you're
going to be successful with now because
you want them to be really successful
and talk about you right and then you
can move on to the others where maybe
there's something that's a little bit
more challenging or maybe the market fit
isn't perfect or whatever else so that's
been like one of the big challenges
uh or surprises i would say
um but you know it's a super positive
sort of thing and you know i'm grateful
for for the great partnerships we have
with these people
i love it i love it and if you're
looking now at some some things that i
can take with me as i'm going to be
going on my own journey and myself my
friends
you know things especially specifically
also in our space you know in
engineering you know developer tools and
for for the companies and you have you
have
so many different sides of this company
you have to be both friendly
friendly implementation for the
developers you have to also speak to the
business people you have to be very
mindful of the sensitivity of what
you're doing what are some non-trivial
things that i should be taking with me
from your experience as i go on my own
journey as an entrepreneur yeah so look
i think the the main takeaways i think
as especially as you move into this ceo
sort of role is
you can't please everybody right and so
a lot of the things that i said earlier
in terms of making priorities sometimes
there's going to be hard decisions and
hard conversations that need to be had
right so first off it's really
identifying those things okay so we
can't do this right then the secondary
thing is never closing a door right
because just because you can't do it
today doesn't mean that it might not be
the right thing to do in six months or
nine months the trick and the essence of
how to thread this needle
is to figure out how to build a
relationship with the other people who
you're going to say no or not now to in
such a way that they're not like okay
well these guys are jerks and they're
not going to do it you have to get to a
state where they understand and this by
the way this isn't my theory and
management as well right you have to get
to a place where the people you're
working with up b-day managers partners
customers whatever
understand the reasons why
you're making the decisions so they can
buy into them right they may not like it
right people don't like being told no
but they have to understand okay got it
if i you know like if i'm not gonna do
this thing it's gonna like the the whole
company is gonna be a problem or
whatever else right it's up you need to
make sure that you're diplomatically
telling people
the the things that need to be told hard
or otherwise
um and making sure they understand once
you have that level of transparency your
trust level goes up they respect you a
lot more um and they're much more likely
to call you uh and check in and say hey
is the time right now right and so
that's that's that's the thing that over
time you have to learn and once you do
you know it makes life actually a lot
easier
incredible gary i really want to thank
you
it's such an interesting perspective
interesting career and i love you know
the time and place that you're in and
the way that you're running this
show and the insights that you have with
it and um you know i'm sold on the the
problem space and i'm looking forward to
trying out the product myself but but
this is a pain this is a real pain and i
think what i love about this type of
company
is that it's a pain that one that you
know it's it's not trivial to understand
the impact that this is going to have
you know on the ripple effect but at the
end
software's hitting the world software
runs on data this is enabling the data
to actually be understood and so um you
know it's all pyramid and this is a
foundation and so best of luck with
archaeon i hope that you can solve this
pain uh for all of us and stay safe and
stay healthy awesome thank you so much
for having me michael it's a real
pleasure all right
thank you take care
[Music]